[Music]
and you are not the father news oh you
have a body
it was Maury Povich okay submitted by
Stacy's mom is that a woman faces 12
months in jail after faking a DNA
paternity test to trick her ex-lover oh
that's sweet but she goes to jail taking
the baby I know I was just thinking that
same thing because I don't have an
answer for that question
that's really stupid that reminds me of
a film that I just rewatched yesterday I
haven't seen years Forrest Gump why I
love Forrest Gump for visca your friend
man that [ __ ] [ __ ] Jenny she gave
him a she gave him you know
I think she gave him eight and on top of
that out of nowhere she comes out she
goes well Forrest that's four words
junior and the poor is being the dumbass
of the heirs obviously in the film he
goes well you named him Forrest - is I
know that's your kid doesn't even know
if it's good or not but the guy was rich
from the shipping company yep came a
gajillion air risk as well - suddenly
that kid is his Jenny you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I thought the whole time when I saw that
movie as a kid - I was like you know he
doesn't even know that's your yeah and
he so dummy just taking care of the kid
yeah she [ __ ] ruined everything
he loves her so yeah imagine if she was
never a part of his life he wouldn't
have those million dollars but then at
the same time though in the beginning of
the film she was sexually abused by her
father so she has a lot of my internal
issues and on top of that that was force
his only friend growing up you have been
here for I didn't know that she was
getting sexually abused until I was
older yeah until I watched it recently
so her name is Danielle and she
convinced or she fabricated the CMA test
about this man named Jamie
saying that he was a father of her baby
named Darcy by the way ladies names
Darcy
like if you get beat up yeah and so this
dude gave me a girl and I was a girl
Oh like I said I'll give you look nah my
kids get beat up on a daily basis based
on names okay so I don't think you could
beat a based on their names yeah I don't
know want our sea legs our seasoning
Darcy Darcy does Jamie he's a
entertainer and musician is important
and he is saying that this whole thing
is so heartbreaking because this lady
pretty much sold her child from Lenny
because he had to pay child support and
he would even like you know have the
baby stay over his home and Mikey would
take care of her bathed her change her
feed her do everything because he
thought that was his daughter what a
responsible daddy yeah and then he's
saying like you pretty much gave your
kid to a stranger for money
yeah [ __ ] up I was really a stranger
they were in a relationship they had
sexual relations with each other but
they weren't really like Orson girls
like a hookup yeah look like a hookup
uh-huh we had hooked up about four times
and that's why he believed that that was
his daughter
and so he even got a footlong tattoo of
her name oh no Bob
don't act hood like that people man so
this is the only fun I could get of the
mine and make sense I don't want to get
a tattoo of my child's leg you're going
to be a [ __ ] up a lot later this is
Jamie uh-huh this is a tattoo whoa
oh he just like tattoos in general yeah
nice tattoo thank you okay you still
going to take care of the kid though
access the mom's gone for 12 12 months
it's a good question I want her to find
out too like what's going to happen to
this little girl and I couldn't find the
old welcome home octa I mean if he's
been raising her as like a little baby
and how old are they now 6 3 3 I'm
supposed to cure the kid my sees them as
a father figure the court probably does
too you know even though they're not
blood-related just the relationship wise
how did he find out that he's not
although the way he found out is because
he any time we had suspicions about like
you know the actual like legitimacy of
that initial DNA test and so he ended up
going off on his own and having his own
DNA test and it came back that he was
not the father and then what did she do
when he was like [ __ ] what is this
that's when he took her to court I'm
assuming it's a favor out of them I mean
she went to jail as of right now they're
still like in report processes but we
don't know yet if she has fully been
convicted to jail so she photoshopped
that [ __ ] she was just like this dude is
the deity she looked on Google Images
yeah she said he was ninety nine point
six percent likely to be the father see
the problem with that is he wasn't there
to wit the blood test and stuff that's
how you check you can't just take a
piece of paper like all on the bed what
I know what proof of how did she get his
info
he made me know how it worked maybe she
still had a little [ __ ] stain right here
she scratched it off into a cup for hose
oh my god that's weird huh maybe he was
just like are a slob here go get the
test done
I guess it's my baby that's responsible
huh yeah you even had like an entire
room in his home for her and Wow wow
what a responsible guy yeah you paid for
you know child support give to her
christening and like my mother cause
there's so many you know guys out there
that thought that's not mine even if
they it is their sanic run away but then
this guy's like immediately well looks
like it's time I'm the daddy ya know I'd
even his entire family to like they were
you know very accepting we get
suspicious but accepting of the daughter
well it's a cute story I wasn't thinking
about it but I yourself gee I'm gonna
keep it that's what they're go that's
what they're saying
I wonder what happens when you have a
kid like that and every time you look at
the kid I'm used to love the child but
you see the runner's face like oh god
your mom is such a [ __ ]
you know but God oh I love you so much
whether that happens to a lot of like
people to have a baby and then like they
have a fight with the baby daddy or the
baby mommy and
like the kid reminds them and I think
that's what happens on my mom yeah I
look just like my dad and like should
tell me that really nice oh yeah you
don't look like your mom no that's true
I should be like you have her eyes you
have just this part of your marketing
Isaac looks just like you I know but
your dad I'm not want to get angry yeah
yeah I've you know literally you see a
photo of his dad and Isaac's like how
are they related you can't see it at all
looks more like a Caesar ya know just
more like you see that's true now you
see like oh like that could be his kid
he did five DNA test five of them just
to make sure five because he was like I
just gotta make sure it's crazy then
every time it was like nope nope nope no
juice
what were the percentages at the same
time I mean I guess he has a loving
daughter so he could take care of I mean
and then when she's gonna turn 18 and be
a little [ __ ] me as [ __ ] and you're
like damn I wasted all his time in
Turkey so me I don't know if I would be
able to take care of a baby for three
years though it's not my kid any morning
I feel like it's not fair for me to
remove this kid from her biological dad
I'd be like I'll be your uncle like call
me uncle I can't do that especially if
that kids already calmed me down you
would kill the kids are you was really
he would be softest I'll do it you
adopted rats for crying out loud well
it's a whole different responsibility
no it's even more if we're gonna stop
the rat I'm a doctor not kid all right
that's some good logic fine
your turn imagine else all you're
talking about oh it's not my service
hahaha
fine you get it using logic yeah man
you take care of that kid in a second
but even I would if I dedicated three
years of my life well you know what you
might not be my kid but once I can call
me daddy that's my child yes miss mine I
gotta raise you up to be my personal
assassin I wanna go ahead teacher to get
[ __ ] you [ __ ] much I wanna get
to know my daughter what you should have
done that earlier you know what I'll
calculate how much it cost me to raise
your daughter till this age right
[ __ ] pay me that money or else you
don't get to see her at all
yeah that's smart yeah how come he did
go go through all the diapers the barb
down
it's going to happen I want him to
change my diaper for about two years I'm
going to take a big [ __ ] [ __ ] in and
I'm gonna lay there like Oh daddy is
tired of me okay so like my so too are
like more infuriating because this girl
Danielle she would boast to her friends
saying like oh this is the Jaime Sommers
show I'm gonna take him for everything
you've got and I see what he's what a
shady [ __ ] so all her friends you know
he was mean in the bad it seems like it
well her friends her friends are garbage
cans why is there so many like garbage
kind of people because I feel like all
these kids that grew up in these
environment like they already want to be
but then like since everyone around them
is like that and then they get up and
they go all what everyone thinks is cool
I'm gonna do it too
I'm going to try to like have a baby and
pretend like it's somebody else's baby
and thence to you hello my mother Joe
Malians please like the video and for
more beautiful videos look up there
[Music]